we the united states of america stand
with the ukrainian people
throughout our history
we've learned this lesson
when dictators
do not pay a price for their aggression
they cause more chaos
they keep moving and the costs the
threats to the america and america to
the world
keeps rising
that's why the nato alliance was created
to secure peace and stability in europe
after world war ii
the united states is a member
along with 29 other nations
it matters
american diplomacy matters
american resolve matters
putin's latest attack on ukraine was
premeditated and totally unprovoked
he rejected repeated repeated efforts at
diplomacy
he thought the west and nato wouldn't
respond
he thought he could divide us at home
in this chamber in this nation
he thought he could divide us in europe
as well
but putin was wrong
we are ready we are united and that's
what we did we stayed united we prepared
extensively and carefully we spent
months building coalitions of other
freedom-loving nations in europe and the
americas to america to the asian and
african continents
to confront putin
like many of you i spent countless hours
unifying near our european allies
we shared with the world in advance what
we knew putin was planning and precisely
how we would try to falsify
and justify his aggression
we countered russia's lies with the
truth
and now
now that he's acted
the three free world was holding him
accountable
along with 27 members of the european
union including france germany italy as
well as countries like the united
kingdom canada japan korea australia new
zealand and many others even switzerland
are inflicting pain on russia
and supporting the people of ukraine
putin is now isolated from the world
more than he has ever been
together
[Music]
together
[Music]
together along with our allies we are
right now enforcing powerful economic
sanctions
we're cutting off russia's largest banks
in the international financial system
preventing russia's central bank from
defending the russell
ruble making putin's 630 billion dollar
war fund worthless
we're choking russia's access
to choking russia's access to technology
that will sap its economic strength and
weaken its military for years to come
tonight
i say to the russian oligarchs and the
corrupt leaders who built billions of
dollars off this violent regime no more
the united states
i
mean united states
department of justice is assembling a
dedicated task force to go after the
crimes of the russian oligarchs
we're joining with european allies to
find and seize their yachts their luxury
apartments they're private jets
we're coming for you ill-begotten gains
and tonight
i'm announcing that we will join our
allies in closing off american airspace
to all russian flights further isolating
russia and adding additional squeeze on
their economy
[Music]
he has no idea what's coming
the ruble has already lost 30 percent of
its value
the russian stock market has lost 40
percent of its value
and trading remains suspended
the russian economy is reeling
and putin alone is the one to blame
together with our allies
we're providing support to the
ukrainians in their fight for freedom
military assistance
economic assistance humanitarian
assistance we're giving more than a
billion dollars of direct assistance
ukraine and will continue to aid
ukrainian people as they defend their
country and help ease their suffering